hey guys my name is Jess it is Friday
and I have forgotten to bring another
shut for friday news so now you know
that Thursday and Friday is shot on the
same day the illusions shattered let's
keep going a new video from the romance
guys doing the rounds to answer the
persistent fan question what the hell
they actually do in this game the video
shows off some of the more aggressive
ways you can conduct yourself in the
universe from engaging in epic space
battles to shooting alien enemies on the
ground basically if you want to fight
you'll be more than able to do so last
week a video was released showing all
the ways you can simply explore the
galaxy so that's more your speed you'll
be able to check out a selection of the
18 quintillion planets that way the
final two videos entitled trade and
survival will presumably be showcasing
those two features no man's sky drew out
on organized well the Warcraft Legion
expansion is on the horizon but before
you get back into that a huge update has
landed for the ever popular MMO the pre
expansion update adds a new
transmogrification system that unlocks
the look of an item account-wide once
it's bound to you it also adds class
specific changes including adjustments
to specializations you'll find it's no
easier to switch between specs and it
won't be as necessary to swap out your
gear since certain item stats will no
longer be tied to specs while graphics
are also getting a boost with improved
color rendering and better looking
effect for the full list of changes
arriving in the patch check out our
story on games but there's no way we
could have gone another week of gaming
news without a mention of Pokemon ghost
those fears that a report revealed that
on July 10 Pokemon goes in Game
microtransactions made up forty seven
percent of all the money people spent on
mobile games that day basically that
means poke one go almost made more
revenue in one day than every other
mobile game combined research company
slice intelligence reports of the app
may also be bringing in first time
mobile game spenders around fifty three
percent of users who spent money on
Pokemon go that day had made
all 0 mobile game purchases in the last
month the most popular in game purchase
is the 100 poker coin bundle although
the app has made most of its money from
the ten-dollar 1200 poker coin bundles
this week Microsoft announced when the
xbox one s will be hitting shelves a
four-hundred-dollar two terabyte model
is going to be arriving first on august
to why the 351 terabyte and 310 500
gigabyte models are expected to land in
this December the Xbox one is forty
percent smaller than the original xbox
one comes with an internal power supply
and supports HDR image processing it
also comes with a fancy new controller
which can be purchased separately for 60
bucks beginning august to microsoft have
assured that all existing xbox one games
accessories and Xbox Live services will
work on Xbox one s finally rise of the
Tomb Raider is coming to ps4 and it will
feature VR support rise of the Tomb
Raider will arrive on October 11 in a
new twenty year celebration edition for
ps4 this version will feature a new
storage have their calls blood ties that
will have playstation vr support you'll
also get all previously released dlc new
outfits and weapons expedition cards and
a limited edition art book pc and xbox
one players who own the season pass will
get all this content to that this won't
include the VR support the new edition
also includes coop endurance gameplay a
zombies mode called Lara's nightmare and
a new extreme survivor difficulty
settings this week on site we go over
the best and worst ghostbusters game
tell you why you should really try your
hand play dead inside and talk about the
stupidest Pokemon ghost stories that is
everything I have for you this week so
be sure to have yourselves a lovely
weekend and the Americans will be taking
care of your news needs next week I'll
catch you after that